Nó này mục bà thành sau năm 2018, kìm lớn đồng này cho biết tại Sà Mà Đà, khiển vincu đồng này
bông như dân vừa bị vòi dừng tính công sĩnh để từ vòng.
Thông tin bà đầu khoảng 18 giờ hôm qua, người dân phát hiện đàn vòi, khoảng 4 kả thịt,
mất đầu dí chuyển vào khu tục sĩ người dân cạnh tác, sắp xanh với khu tục dừng tự nhiên của khu bảo tôn
thiên nhiên, bân hóa đồng này, phá hoà mồng, đàn vòi sơ đó đã dát dí chuyển vào lại khu tục dừng tự nhiên.
Để khoảng 20 giờ của ngày, đàn vòi trên tiếp tục dí chuyển để khu tục sĩ nhà ông liên văn thật,
sống sảo tự của ông muốn, Sà Mà Đà, để tiền kiếm tức ăn.
Hí thế đàn vòi, ông thận tiến hành suốt đổi thịt bị vòi dừng tính công,
để khoảng sấu dờ hôm nay người dân phát hiện thịt tự ông thận tự vong tại khu tục nơi trên.
Hám nghiệm hiện chương, các quan chức năng sát định, viên bà đầu khiến ông thận tự vong rồi bị vòi quận,
suốt trường quả trình suốt đường.
Ông thận là hộ nhận đất sảo quan quay khu bảo tổn tiến, văn hóa đồng này.
Hơi ra gần đây, đàn vòi dừng thử xin xuất hiện ở khu vực biệt dừng bà gần hú dừng cơ của những kí cử
tục địa bản lắm phần còn li của khu bảo tổn tiến, văn hóa đồng này, để tiền kiếm tức ăn,
phá hả thóa mọt, tại sản của mình.